[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi i'm dan hayes i'm joined by my
co-host dr greg sadler and today we're
talking about
when your heroes let you down so we've
got a lot of stuff lined up about role
models and mentors and other people that
we might be looking up to emulating
guiding our lives by i mean what else
would you throw in there dan um
taking actual advice from
right and so that's a special type of
role model that we'll talk about as a
mentor um but yeah that you've got both
uh people that you don't know and people
you do know that people you're emulating
people that you
um may want to
uh avoid the same decisions that they
make
yeah and role models are
not so much mentors because they have to
have a a possibility of telling you
things in the present but role models
could be people from
ancient times who we think there's
something to when we model ourselves off
of although when people ask us you know
who are your heroes you know if you say
somebody like brexit us the spartan
they might look at you a little bit
weird so who's that guy or uh and you
know especially now that we've had the
what is it the 300 was that the movie
where uh they they had kind of a wrong
portrayal of him
um i mean i used to actually say that
because i thought he was a cool guy from
reading um thucydides and you know
hearing about him as the
the savior of greece the person who is
freeing
greek city-states from the evil empire
of the athenians who turned out to be a
tyrant city but you know when somebody
on the street asks you about that you
say yeah this guy
they probably have no idea what you're
talking about and i i wonder i mean this
is so this is totally
uh
a curveball to start with but i mean do
you think that when it comes to our
the people that we model ourselves off
of the people that we look to
do you think that there's a lot of cases
where other people just don't get it
they don't know who these people are
for
most people
i mean if you say well martin luther
king or mother teresa everybody knows
who they are right although most people
don't actually
read their their stuff so they don't
know that much about them but but you
know for more obscure characters do you
think that's part of what's motivating
people or if you say oh my grandma well
i don't know your grandma
well i don't think like the whole point
of it i think for
the point of a role model is is personal
like you don't have to
you know justify
exactly to anyone else why
you're modeling yourself off of someone
unless you're like oh well i'm doing
this thing that seems crazy yeah well
why
well this guy he wouldn't see him um i'm
modeling myself after um rasputin like
oh maybe we should like talk about that
uh that's one of those things though
where it would be difficult to really do
that you got to find a royal family to
glom onto it i mean how many people have
that opportunity right uh yeah
that's another kind of interesting point
so
when do we
say to people i think you're right that
most of the time we don't have to
justify it we're like well who are your
heroes oh these are my heroes and you
know we make exercises like this in
class
but if you say something really off the
wall like if you said well my hero is
this horrible villain
in this this movie you know or yeah i i
want to be like darth vader right yeah
i think people
i don't know that they would say well
you're you're bad because of that but i
think they would think that you are at a
greater risk maybe for
for going bad
right
ah so
i think we should really talk about like
what what we really mean here by my role
models so uh you know they're definitely
people that you admire and for most
people these are people that you um you
kind of like hold up at least to a
certain extent on a pedestal and that we
want to
uh emulate some of the things that
they've done uh maybe to um hope to
uh achieve some of the accolades that
they had done in their own lives in as
their future selves
um
and you know i guess when we were
talking about a little bit earlier it's
like what is a mentor but a mentor is on
this special type of role model in which
you actually have you know
direct interaction so they can actually
give you advice
and so on
we have a quote from
seneca here about uh why a mentor and he
says choose a master whose life
conversation and soul expression
face
have satisfied you picture him always to
yourself as your protector or your
pattern
for we must indeed have someone
according to whom we may regulate our
characters and can never straighten that
which is crooked unless you use a ruler
so
what we have here is you know
we are making decisions and how can we
choose if our decisions are
good or bad if you don't have any
criteria for what makes them that way
so this is using the
person as a sort of criteria or canon
is the ancient greek term
you know for the ruler right um
and so
there's kind of a two-sidedness to this
right on the one hand we don't say well
that person is my
model and anything they do is exactly
what i need to do
they have to be judged according to some
sort of standards of good or bad right
so if they
start screwing up like let's let's say
you've got somebody you pick them out
and they're at like the top of their
game and in the prime of their
development but then they start cutting
corners
i mean this is one of the things that
does happen with with uh role models and
mentors and we're going to talk about
them letting us down in just a bit
that's how they do it right and you're
like oh i don't know about that i mean
there you're faced with a decision then
do you follow along and you're like well
you know in for a penny in for a pound i
guess i gotta follow this person the
whole way down or do you say well i
think i need to
make some distinctions here i'll go
along with him on one thing but
not another thing right
right that
you know especially if you're the person
that you are following is alive you know
but once you get that fame and that
those accolades yeah a lot of people can
easily sit on their laurels and the the
things that you used to
admire in them
um
kind of go to the wayside as they they
no longer have to you know struggle so
hard to
uh like they did early in life or
they
once again you know as we'll talk about
in depth is like what happens when
you find out that uh what you knew about
them was a facade or at least only a
portion of their character and then you
see the full extent of it
well before we get to that let's talk a
bit more about like why why we need role
models i mean somebody could come along
and say
you're better off without any role
models nobody can let you down
you know you're totally free to decide
your own path at that point and i i
don't i don't find that convincing
myself you know
i tend to think that even if we are
accomplished or have great qualities or
you know are genuine
generally on the right track and can be
trusted
we probably still need to look to other
people
at least to tell us hey man don't screw
up in this way you know or
for accountability or something like
that
i mean what what's
what's your view on that
uh yeah like
it's
one thing to like have some sort of like
theory or basis that you're like trying
to follow through on
but um
it's a lot easier to kind of just
emulate the actions you know a lot of
times there's a lot of
talk about praxis as the okay
uh combination of both theory and
practice in a particular study the
philosophy of religion
on and
that
sometimes it's easier to watch someone
that's already gone through
and apply both of these things um
and to see how they react in the
specific situations okay um i can see
from the way that they react from this
potentially difficult situation on how
someone that has already mastered these
skills
is over able to
uh react in you know a calm way or like
in a
commanding way whatever thing that
you're trying to emulate okay
yeah i mean aristotle you know one of
the big uh early theorists of virtue
ethics which is part of what we're
talking about here modeling ourselves
after somebody else's character
when he's talking about what it is to
act virtuously he says you know well
it's got to be based in a habit
and there's all these other things but
one of the things that's i always
thought was kind of cool that a lot of
people find confusing and circular he
says a person
who is temperate has to do things
the way the temperate person does them
and meaning that there's there's
something like
i don't know what do you want to call it
there's like a
an approach to things and you can't put
it neatly into words or rules or stuff
like that but you watch somebody enough
and you're like oh okay i get it i get
how they would make a decision in this
circumstance that i'm facing that they
never faced before because i've spent
enough
time and
paid enough attention and gave enough
thought to the way that they
interact with the world and other people
and themselves and he says that this is
really something central to to good
behavior to virtuous behavior
and again i think a lot of people when
they read that they're like well that is
just circular acting temperate means
acting like the tempered person well
what the hell is temperate then well you
know he talks about that in other places
but i but i think that the guidelines
that he gives
you need something going beyond that and
that's where a role model could come in
or even better a mentor like a coach
like somebody who can who takes an
interest in you and says i want
you to be able to do
what it is that i can do or i want to
bring out the potential that's in you
um and you know many of us are
maybe not fortunate enough to have
mentors
or we have you know people who are not
very good mentors but if you have a
really good mentor boy i think that
makes a huge difference
right and
the the thing he's saying about like
this the tempered person does what a
type of person does
as you said it does sound
kind of circular but that sounds really
circular but that is really the the core
of how we generally learn as humans like
think of like us gathering language we
watch other people talk and then we
emulate that and we start to babble and
we start to like oh well now i i saw
them making a d sound and you know i
don't know have a concept of d sounds
yet but i can mimic this back and forth
until eventually we're starting to make
full words where we're
imbuing meaning to
these early words and this opens up more
pathways for us to do this better and
eventually we become
um first in language and only once we
have one language then do we have like
oh let's have books to describe the
second language that you want to learn
but that is not exactly that's
absolutely not the way that we learned
our first languages
this reminds me of something a kind of
thing
let's call it a mix-up that happened in
the history of philosophy
there's this really famous guy ludwig
wittgenstein you know major
uh catalyst for
the turn to focusing on on language in
the early 20th century in analytic
philosophy and also influenced some
people on the continent as well
and he criticizes augustine because he's
talking about augustine's confessions
very early on where augustine talks
about children learning language
and he says he takes a couple lines
basically out of context and ignores the
rest and he says augustine is is
essentially saying that that words are
just used to
index things they they refer to things
and you know the kid you know watches
the parent maybe pointing at something
and saying
you know and now the
water bottle is is that you know
and
it's funny because
and this is going to sound like a a dig
on witt and shine and i guess it is
wickenshine would have been a much
better philosopher had he read other
philosophers a bit more attentively and
if you'd read more philosophers
because augustine doesn't isn't saying
that at all i mean he is saying that but
but it's within this whole context where
he's like the reason why we want as
infants to say words is we have needs
and desires and you know drives and
and we want to communicate them to other
people so that's what's centering us to
pay attention to what it is that these
adults or you know kids who can speak
in front of us are calling things and it
takes us a while to put it together and
figure out what things are actually
called and we and we're very
enthusiastic about it at the start
because we want our needs
met you know this this whole thing is is
driving it and that kind of fell out of
the
the picture and how we can bring this
back to talking about um role models and
mentors is you know this is something
that we
i think most people
even if they're kind of jaded they
really do want somebody to
look up to
even if they're
cynical and they're like you know people
in general are garbage
very often there's like a little bit of
idealism still under there they want
somebody to at least be a good person if
not them
somebody that they could point to
can you be completely cynical if you
weren't
at one point at least partially and
idealist um
that's a good question and
i think we may have talked about this on
the show before there's this uh
correlation that socrates made between
what he called mis misalogism which
we'll put on the side and then
misanthropy
and misanthropy is hatred of human
beings right literally
misos is hatred and then anthropos is
the generic word for human beings men
and women both you know
and and sometimes anthropology yeah
exactly yeah the study of of human being
and so socrates says how do people
become
misanthropic
um it's because they start out too
trusting
they
treat people as if they're
totally good
and this is i think this is directly uh
connected to what we're going to talk
about here right they have these
unrealistic expectations of people then
they get let down and they're like oh
that person's a jerk you know they
they're a hypocrite they didn't measure
up to the standards that i was holding
them to and then they're like well the
next time around it's going to be
perfect i'll find another role model and
they won't let me down at all and then
of course they get let down right person
after person after after person and then
they draw this sweeping conclusion
people are just all bad
and socrates says well that's you know
that's not a good conclusion to draw
it's not warranted in the circumstances
because what what made
for these unpleasant experiences
trusting people too much you know it's
not like you should
trust absolutely you should trust in a
rational kind of
uh people meriting more and more trust
as they do things sort of way you know
and we see this in relationships a lot
too right romantic relationships people
are out there i found the one and then
the one turns out to be kind of a jerk
or abusive or exploitative
and then they you know they move on from
that relationship to the next one that
looks almost exactly like the previous
one
and it just happens over and over right
right and the issue here is that like
you're not at least one of the issues is
that you're
not uh
being aware of the fact that we are
human that we are or flawed we will
yeah even if most of the times we're
doing great and we're going to
make all those dates and not let them
down like life happens and and sometimes
we're tired and sometimes like stuff
just
happens and
you have to realize that that is part of
being a human to being in this world
so let's conjecture why do you think
people
do ignore that so often
and they have these
you know it's not as if they don't know
the other person is human
but it's as if they think that in this
case this particular human is not going
to screw up they're like a god or
something you know
where do you think that comes from
like total conjecture here like part of
this is like it's easier to
um
say this person is good like i love this
person so of course they're good right
and and so that's all you need to know
uh and so all their from that you know
we talked about this before you label
someone good then all of a sudden all
their actions
on
after that are are good but once you are
smashed in the face with an action that
wasn't as good yeah now that that starts
to destroy that entire facade uh because
you had built up this you know this
perfect
you know simulacrum that doesn't
actually map on to the human i'm sorry
simulacrum is a a poor representation of
that that's actually a great idea to
bring in though i think that in a lot of
cases when people get into arguments for
example
they're they're not arguing with the
person in front of them they're arguing
with an image of that person that
they've got stuck up on their head and
that's why they say crazy stuff you know
like well you always and then they're
like where's this coming from you know
um well the uh the person in my head
always does that sort of thing and so it
does make sense that people would
would say that that sort of thing and i
guess what you're talking about is the
opposite right where
it's this wonderful wonderful person who
never does anything wrong as we used to
like say
butter wouldn't melt in their mouth
and then suddenly
the the real person out there is doing
doing evil deeds and
you're like
there's a cognitive dissonance right
right right and then how do you you know
that that
that wave function collapses and has to
be one of the other or something i feel
like
i am not um
bursting up in quantum physics so you
can bring that forwards i will retract
that um so okay uh
so maybe um
let us uh go back here and grab just uh
what do we mean by mentor we talked
about it just a little bit but it is
definitely bi-directional
so we have actual interactions so this
is a you want to call it a special type
of
um
hero or role model in which you have
their
experience but they're also
teach you hopefully
give you active engagement advice and
whereas uh as we've just talked about on
our last episode on role models in which
you have no engagement are a little bit
similar to
those parasocial relationships
and so where this is where uh you you
only get to see so much they put on a
facade and
you know
or maybe they're not just like you may
only know so much about them especially
if they're like from the ancient world
how much are you actually going to know
about them except for some of their most
deeds that happen to get you know
written down and passed on uh maybe he
was a jerk that kicked dogs you don't
know
yeah and we have a whole host of what
we're calling parasocial relationships
which aren't aren't truly relationships
because they do lack that
engagement back and forth
we talked about this at
considerable length in a previous
episode that you can you can look up if
you'd like to
um and i was thinking as you're talking
about that so a lot of the parasocial
relationships that we talked about in
that episode were in the present like
athletes and actors and
rock stars and politicians
yeah influencers yeah yeah
people that we can't possibly
have a
um a relationship with
in part because
we would only get a certain amount of
time with these these people right
but
so in academic philosophy it's not
unusual
to see people
and i bet this holds for other fields as
well where they develop this very
strong
relationship with the person that they
they think is important to work on right
you know like i'm into aristotle i have
to look at the world the way that
aristotle does and read his books and
spend time you know we talk about like
having this conversation across the ages
with with people we brought up seneca
earlier somebody who i'm you know his
big favorite of mine i think one of one
of yours as well
and um seneca is pretty cool because
he's pretty modest about stuff he's like
yeah i'm not a sage you know i'm i'm
screwing up a lot of the time here's
here's what i know and i got this mostly
from other people uh but we can look at
him and be like ah he's he's a good guy
you know um i i like this seneca fellow
and um i wish i could be friends with
him you know but we can't because he's
he's dead he's been dead for
not quite uh two thousand years but
it's getting 1700 years yeah no no more
than
he he was a contemporary with epictetus
basically a little bit earlier right
because they're all at the time in nero
so
yeah 1800 1900 years uh i mean once once
we get further into this century
so you know what's up with that i mean
we also talked about fictional
characters too
and could you could you have an adequate
fictional character as a role model
i don't know that's kind of tough
go ahead there are benefits that you
know they can't let you down
they that never actually existed so they
don't have the
oil being human
unless unless uh it it's somebody who's
still writing that character right they
could
they could have them turn out to be evil
in the end or something like that right
but yeah you're right if it's if it's
sherlock holmes i don't know why you
would want to model yourself after
sherlock holmes because he's he's kind
of a jerk and you know he's he's
talented but he's also kind of a hot
mess but let's say you did
that's true
yeah there's there's been some papers
devoted to like unpacking
logic and the story whatever is left
however improbable must be the answer no
you how do you know that the
list of the possibilities that you
looked at is exhausted yeah and where is
this principle coming from too you know
well from the mind of arthur conan doyle
who is
if i remember famously suckered by
what was it the piltdown man or it was
some hoax that he got taken in by
himself
yeah
was he also in the seances i feel like
spiritualism could could be i i don't
quite remember but in any case like
so you know if you took sherlock holmes
as your role model well yeah he's not
going to change unless people are
writing fan fiction in you know or
redoing sherlock like think of the
sherlock show that had benedict
cumberbatch
and for robert downey jr oh true true
yeah now that's that was a
interesting one
yeah and so okay so that's kind of
interesting
because that means that any fictional
character
isn't really set in stone
because people can't especially if it's
in the public domain right people can go
at it
and well maybe if you like curtail it
it's like okay only the sherlock holmes
that arthur conan door right
yeah sherlock holmes the original right
yeah
yeah
i mean it's kind of funny because if you
think about i hate to take it so far off
track but think about the batman right
so
you know who's the original batman if
we're talking about tv stuff it's that
goofy guy played by adam west
who's powing and bapping and
same bat time same bad place exactly
now then later on we get um you know
still kind of cartoonish with michael
keaton
and the joker but there's more menace
there and nowadays like people are
making jokes about like how dark the
batman movies are getting and they're
they're like well the next time around
it'll just be a black screen and there
won't be anything you'll just hear some
muffled
things like that so you know which which
is the which is the original
is it the kind of buffoonish character
at the beginning is it somebody nice in
the middle is it the dark knight you
know the scary guy
um which which is your role model you
know
you have to decide on at least one of
them because you can't possibly cram all
of them together in one composite
hero i think can you right
no
no but like the the corpus of the batman
is is too large to be able to like
that there's definitely some
through lines
you know we've got it's like a a normal
distribution you've got like the through
lines in the center okay almost all the
batman's happen
tail ends they go forever you can get
some really
weird and interesting
versions for example it seems like
more people
are into the
dark gritty batman though than the
more wholesome
you know
come on robin we'll go beat up these bad
guys kind of kind of batman
um so i think we should uh come back
here just a little bit rope us back in
yeah
so we talked about like there's uh we
talked about aristotle on that uh it
uses role models as as we just talked
about earlier seneca is talking about
role models and so uh the stoics also
have this christianity and the whole hey
what would jesus do once again here's a
role model
and and this is a through line and many
others so this is definitely
that's an interesting one too though i
just want to point this out
there's so many contemporary christians
when they talk about you know jesus this
and jesus that you're like have you ever
read the gospels because what you're
saying seems very very different than
the original text you know
jesus where's this like
jesus new you know 15th iteration coming
in who's mostly obsessed with like
people's sexuality or you know purity or
things like that coming from right this
reminds me of a
buddy christ if you've ever seen a
dogma um
kevin smith's movie oh right yeah yeah
um totally reimagining of it
uh but yeah like yes it can get rather
fraught on with different
interpretations but at least there is
the idea of a role model um regardless
of the exact
instantiation of it
yeah that's quite true and we can say
this about um pretty much all the world
religions right
um try to be like the you know the
buddha yeah i mean and then there's all
sorts of well what would he what would
he do in this case well you know there's
a lot of back and forth about that and
you know the the sage plays an important
role in
uh confucianism and and in uh taoism and
quite a few other
major wisdom traditions you could call
them
so
yeah
uh
definitely and and so like
i don't know i guess this is just giving
backing that we're not just you know
talking about a useless topic here that
people haven't found use in other places
um but um
and then as what you said earlier like
talking about like oh i have to read
aristotle and i have to like really dig
into his mind
this also happens in academic philosophy
yeah
but the issue here
is role models fail us they fail us all
the time and how do we
deal with that you know how do we square
the circle this is an impossible
question
you know you have a role model and as we
were talking about with relationships we
put them on a pedestal and then
they make decisions that we totally
disagree with or we
failed to measure up to the measure that
they were the measure of yeah or at
least we find kind of sketchy right and
we're we're like i'm not sure about this
one
yeah
so that that's that's a common problem
is i i would actually say that that
might be part of normal human
development too like picking out people
who you think are
really good to model yourself after
investing in them emotionally and then
being let down and then what do you do
after that you know and it could be a
gym coach it could be
uh a teacher it could be
you know an important athlete that you
see playing
uh i mean athletes are great for
providing us with all sorts of
unedifying examples once we actually
start looking at their their personal
life
right
so we have a couple of strategies for
what happens when they fail us and so
yeah first one as we talked about a
little bit before is realize that your
role model is not perfect
ah they are human they will fail you
another strategy well before we go on to
that i mean i think that people when
they they hear that
they're tempted to say oh yeah yeah
nobody's perfect sure whatever you know
but we should we should try to get them
to think well why did you come to think
that they were perfect in the first
place where was that coming from was
that a justified
assumption or judgment on your part was
somebody else telling you that they were
i mean you could you could be belonging
to a
group or culture where somebody is held
up as like this person is is you know
the best they can never do anything
wrong i mean going back to the jesus
thing right so you know jesus uh shows
you the example you should always be
nice and kind and and meek and stuff
like that and then you know you read the
gospels and you're like
well there was that day in the temple
right
and in the gospel of mark if i remember
right and actually uses the word anger
for for what he was experiencing
and so you know if you've got this
mistaken
image in your mind you can ask well
where did i get this mistaken image from
why is it so unrealistic you know as to
not have any wiggle room
so
yeah i think that is
uh
an issue
so maybe we'll we'll have some other
ways to uh deal with this and so next
one is
compartmentalization
um that the things that they are good
about them and imitate only those things
and let the other things you know sit a
little the wayside
that's another one too where i think a
lot of people
they have a hard time with that because
they're like listen if you're going to
imitate somebody you have to imitate
everything that they do otherwise you're
not really following them you're not
modeling yourself after them
and so we probably need to like make
some sort of case
why it's okay
and not only okay but but better to
compartmentalize like you're saying i
mean to me it's kind of a no-brainer
it's right rational and it's it's easier
for certain role models if you have like
a role model that is like
a really good athlete you can
you can more easily compartmentalize
their
uh actions on the field of play versus
those are not that's easier but once you
have like a
moral role model or someone that you're
trying to
uh emulate your day-to-day life with
this becomes more difficult because
that's a much more holistic role model
and so i'm going to skip down a little
bit just uh we're
talking about you know what we expect
from these role models we expect them to
be uh for moral role models to be
morally upstanding to possess some
virtue and to not falter um but once
again
it comes in that same problem of you
know realize that your your role model
is not perfect and
um maybe not all the decisions
are always going to be the correct ones
yeah i think even with people who are
really quite good you know like
certainly beyond the level of goodness
that i have developed in my character
uh i won't speak for you dan um maybe
you're better off than i am in that
respect but you know where i can
recognize that they're really they're
really good people they still screw up
they still
every once in a while lose their temper
misinterpret what somebody's saying
have a bad day and chew somebody out
actually you know this is
we should we should come back to this
point sometime in in an episode i often
tell my students and i've told you this
as well that
a lot of ethics is like figuring out
what to do after you've already screwed
things up right and like how to
extricate
yourself from the
the mess you've created and avoid
hurting people additionally along the
way you know
and i think that that could be something
that
you can only see that in a role model if
they do screw up
right
and
yeah we we just recently did a uh
uh episode on
forgiveness um asking for forgiveness
yeah i'm apologizing and
um yeah uh
that is a incredibly large portion than
that
absolutely ripe uh
and fertile soil for us to dig into
later
yeah
um and so uh the last strategy here for
um if you're holding this person up is
um to make them the rock of your
relationship with the world and then
become totally devastated when they fail
that sounds like a bad strategy it is a
bad strategy but a lot of people choose
it for some reason
you know so let's go back to that
because we we touched on that earlier
why do people do that is it is it that
it does help simplify the world for them
you know you've got the
good people on one side the bad people
on the other side you know it's sort of
like having a brand you know you buy a
certain brand because it's got
reliability
do people actually buy brands for
reliability anymore
well
that is a good question i don't know i
mean
i could say well like heinz ketchup we
keep buying heinz ketchup
um but
it's because we like the taste of that
ketchup better than some of the other
competitors
right we're accustomed to it we're
habituated to it
um
i don't know that it's actually
i don't know that we believe in like on
some unconscious level that it's
reliably
good or something like that and that's
why we do it i suppose we must right
um yeah i'm just thinking of so many
brands nowadays are just built on
marketing and not actually substance
well that's true a lot of
name brands
you are paying for the packaging and you
are paying for
the
marketing that has been bought and paid
for by by the company
and quite often the generic store brands
you know here in in wisconsin it's the
roundies stuff right
out in
north carolina it was food lion in uh
new york it was hannaford there's always
like some brand and it's always like the
same
thing it's all coming from the same
warehouses right and they're
packaged in the same place they just
change out the packaging yeah and
they're cheaper and they're usually just
about as good
because you're not paying for all that
advertising
yeah
so
is there an analogy to people with this
or
i mean you can see people coming
advertise themselves right yeah
i don't know
like as i said that had that conjecture
earlier of like it simplifies things but
um
i don't know uh maybe you just get
convinced um
and and we can become convinced
really easily
think of like how many
people
um you know
are convinced their parents are like
perfect until
they get you know much older you know
um then you realize they're also human
so it's like you know
you can fall into it
people also especially like teenagers
and and 20-somethings have the opposite
thing where they're like mom and dad are
stupid they don't know anything
and then you get a bit older and you're
like oh
okay they weren't perfect but they
actually they were doing pretty good and
they do quite a few things
the pendulum
exactly i guess you can see that it's
like okay i spent the first like 15
years or something of my life you know
idolizing these people
and then and then the facade starts to
crumble and you're like oh and you're
like you're so
aghast at this you're like oh i had to
move away
mom and dad are phonies yes yes
okay holden
exactly
i just want to throw this in holden
caufield the
main character and the catcher in the
rye
he was a role model for a lot of young
men
and he's a terrible role model because
he has nothing to contribute he's just
complaining all the time right
although he does wish to be better than
he is
especially what makes okay so that's
good all right
you're right he's not a good role model
yeah
on
so okay on
so what happens when they do let you
down because they're going to let you
down yeah
so it can throw us into a state of
cognitive dissonance just as we talked
about with the parents on or even
potentially existential crisis that this
this person that you're holding as uh
you know as a pillar of how you
uh
moved in the world um
and now we have to deal with this and so
i guess
an example that is if people like lose
their religion and they have like a
religious figurehead as the person that
was their
moral role model you don't believe this
anymore now now you're like oh shoot
um
what do you do then so um if you've
built your entire life uh around being
and following this person then the
foundations of how one
the processes here we have uh you know
realization and
distancing so
um
now what does that distancing mean what
what is how do you distance are you
talking about like you don't spend any
time with them or
um i think there's uh
trying to
remove yourself from that same thought
patterns if
okay are so disillusioned like instead
of like
okay realizing they're humans so you can
think of this uh
once again the parents
is a great analogy you know uh kids they
love the parents they love them they
come to
teenagers
and you know hormones but also like this
realization that your parents are
actually human and now you're like ah
and i want to get away from them there's
definitely a physically the physical
distancing but it's also like
maybe an emotional and uh
intellectual distance
yeah and i i think that could happen
with other things as well where you're
like you know i used to be like super
into these athletes and the things that
they're doing but now i've realized that
sports aren't quite as important as i
made them out to be like it you change
your perspective right and then you're
like i want to put my time into my
studies or into building a business or
whatever it happens to be
and so this this allows you a
space
for self examination reflection
so now okay well
these people let me down
um
now we can kind of like hopefully look
at things in a little bit more clear
sense we no longer have the rose-colored
glasses of these people on this pedestal
um and then we start looking for our own
way hopefully to like take the things
that we learned
and
progress to make our own path
and realizing that you may not want
to put people up on pedestals in the
first place
yeah
i think that takes a couple tries for a
lot of people
they have to uh
set a couple people up on pedestals have
them knocked down and then at a certain
point they're like well maybe the
problem is the pedestal
[Laughter]
oh
mr id
tear down this wall
of this pedestal
yeah
odd
and
also okay so let's talk about some um
role model traps and it's like when you
imitate someone and you think they're
good but
you don't want to uh imitate the other
things that they do
um because those other actions are bad
or ideas
yeah or unproductive could be you know
like like not not connected directly to
the thing that you're admiring them for
um
i think i i may have brought this up
before in the past but i i was fortunate
enough to study with somebody
who was a second generation student of
ludwig vickenshine the guy that we were
talking about earlier
and
she
was she was a really cool person
unfortunately she died pretty young of
of cancer
and she was a very promising uh
wittgenstein scholar but she'd studied
with these people who had studied with
the master himself and he was an
interesting guy he had a lot to
contribute
but he also had these weird ticks like
he would go in the corner and bang his
head on the wall you know to show that
he was thinking and pondering a problem
and they got the idea these students of
his that that's what philosophy
was and required so then they
started doing that stuff it'd be sort of
like if you know you're studying with a
master chef and he happens to wear a
yellow hat and you're like well yellow
hats that's where it's at you know and
you totally missed the message and she
thought this was terrible she was like
none of you should ever do this you know
i i took classes with these people and
they were good people but man did they
have some
weird ideas about how how philosophers
ought to
behave and so i think sometimes it can
be not necessarily
picking up on
directly bad things but just picking up
on stuff that's like it's not connected
to what it is that you care about you
know it'd be like if you're going
fishing with your grandpa he's going to
teach you how to fish and stuff like
that and then he i don't know he chews
tobacco right that doesn't mean you have
to chew tobacco to fish
right
this reminds me a little bit of the
story of why
uh residents new doctors um have such
long shifts and
the guy who set up
his name on
the the whole schedule like
first guys like okay teach doctors and i
really regimented away at a teaching
hospital
i want them to have 24-hour shifts
because i'm doing 24-hour shifts and
there's at least an argument there that
you get to see the progression of
diseases
yes that was a whole day mom
but he was taking a lot of coke
and so of course he was okay for doing a
24 hour shift he was on a really big
stimulant and so yeah now you're like
okay well now you have to do that but
all you get is like caffeine it's not
gonna like do
the same thing for you as well as it's
totally against
all the new medical evidence about like
being tired and not sleeping has really
bad detrimental effects on
your ability to operate especially when
you're making decisions that might
have not a great idea
yeah i think we could probably multiply
all like in every area of life there's
probably people drawing the wrong
conclusion about how they ought to
behave
by by looking at somebody you know
we got a number of
people here that you know for example
we've got on henry ford and charles
lindbergh pray like you did automation
for henry ford and charles lindbergh you
know flew across the uh atlantic ocean
for the first time very cool things yeah
yeah they're also big um proponents of
fascism they're big fans of the nazis
yeah
but it's probably not something that we
should emulate
um and then you know we've got some more
uh recent people like we've got on elon
musk and jordan peterson i'm like okay
hooray you
build some
really good cars and whatnot but that
does not mean that i need to emulate you
with a lot of their assets
i have happened to see elon musk mostly
because of the accounts that i follow
getting into petty arguments on twitter
with these people who don't have any
anywhere near the following that he does
and wasting hours out of a day just
being a mean-spirited jerk and you're
like how can this guy if i'm a ceo i'm
not spending any time on twitter
somebody else is handling twitter for me
because i'm going to be so busy like
running my
my company you know that i have a
fiduciary duty to that sort of thing
and you're like where does this guy have
the time to be arguing with existential
comics about marxism or anything like
that you know it's it's it's uh it's
definitely not a um
a positive quality on on his part you
know
you know he made a recent bid to take
over twitter and some of us were joking
about you know
why was he doing that you know so that
he'd be able to argue with more people
you know with impunity or something like
that
um
and so then
yes the last one on this list was like
george peterson a lot of people
at least
uh find him interesting goddamn
potentially into
some bits of philosophy um uh but he's
got a lot and he's got some good um
things in
you know psychology but they're
they're not new they're not unique to
him
but also
that's the thing i mean and i think you
can say this not just about like jordan
peterson but you can say it about like
ein rand or you can say it about
other people throughout
you know the the
history of ideas
that
um
it's not as if all their ideas could be
bad you know like aristotle says nobody
can be completely wrong because that
that's just impossible
they often do have some good ideas like
ein rand will use the the term hierarchy
of values and say that you should
actually be thoughtful about how you
organize the values in your life that's
great
but you don't have to go to her to get
that you could get that same idea from
mock shaler the
you know very flawed but very very
brilliant
german
um
you know sociologist of knowledge and
and phenomenologist and
um same thing with jordan peterson he
has
he has some interesting ideas every
interesting idea he has
that's got some value to it you can find
in somebody else without
the baggage
so
so um
so i guess we got this uh
a bit from quotes i do not feel that we
should set up people as models
rather
actions
thoughts
principles
so i i like that
um so uh gnome chancey
american intellectual as well as
one of the
central figures in
linguistics
um
and political theory uh yeah on the left
you know absolutely i i like this idea
i mean i i would kind of amend it and i
would say
that we could set people up as models if
what we're really focusing on and
constantly
coming back to our actions and thoughts
and principles you know it's not like we
want to set somebody up as a model and
then say all right they they're in
now everything they do is a-okay
we have to keep looking at their
actions and thoughts and principles you
know
right and so this is you know definitely
a way of basically doing this
bifurcation of [ __ ] picking and choosing
okay um but even even more
on detailed instead of like
only in this area of sports i'm going to
model him by saying i'm going to take
every action as they take it and see how
if it's good then i'll take it if it's
not i will assure it
okay
you know there was another idea that we
kicked around a little bit earlier
coming back to the jordan peterson but i
think this could apply to a lot of other
thinkers you know like in for example
when we talk about stoicism
ryan holiday has sold a lot of books and
made a lot of money on um you know he's
got the daily stoic and the stuff that
he does it's not it's not i'm not gonna
say it's bad
um i myself personally
um
you know like we have the daily stoic
and we had to quit reading it because
the quotes from the actual stoics were
great the quotes from
for each day from holiday after a point
were like oh come on
this is not necessarily what the
the quote is saying and i don't really
like these examples but
it it you know you could say well he's
brought so many people to
stoic philosophy and we've got this
metaphor of training wheels
you can say that's great you know but
it's just like a bike if you if you
start out with a bike when you're a
little kid you have to have training
wheels and the training wheels help you
out they stabilize the bike you can
actually learn the motions that you need
and you know you pedal around your
everybody's clapping they're proud of
you and all that but at a certain point
the training wheels have to come off
if you're
you know if you're 12 years old and
you've been riding a bike since you were
six and you still have the training
wheels on
something is wrong you know
you you can't progress if you're
constantly keeping the training wheels
there and you know like when it comes to
studying philosophy i tell people ah
don't don't bother with i mean you you
can there's nothing wrong with reading
secondary literature but there's nothing
keeping you from actually reading
seneca or epictetus or marcus aurelius
you know it's not
beyond the average person they just have
been taught that it's it's beyond them
you know
and uh
would you say that for all philosophers
or are there certain oh that's a great
question
um
versa perhaps hegel there are some that
are harder than others yeah hegel is
very high on the level of difficulty and
then we could talk you know much greater
length but i don't want to consume too
much of our time
it's it's in part because he's a bad
writer
he's not a bad thinker but he is he is
not great at expressing himself and that
makes it more difficult you know other
thinkers like emmanuel kant it's like
you got to crack a code and figure out
exactly what the words mean once you've
done that it's a bit easier to put
things
into place but we can say the same thing
about the stoics right they got this
language of the indifference and what
the hell are those right uh i think we
didn't we do a whole episode on on the
indifference at one point potential oh
yeah probably but yeah maybe we'll come
back to it again yeah
um so um
once again like i love this idea of the
training wheels but also um what what's
the flip side of the the model the role
model is an anti-role model and so this
is yeah something that we can also talk
about of like okay what what are the
things that we who are the people or the
actions that we want to not do
right yeah it's like oh oh shoot don't
want to be that guy you know
things that come to mind are like bill
cosby or lance armstrong you know bobby
fischer these are people that like made
some really bad decisions like okay we
all know
maybe o.j simpson yeah bad decisions
were made
don't want to follow those footsteps
yeah so
and we can isolate out what we
don't want about them so that we're not
making the converse mistake of saying oh
everything that they did like if they so
you know bill cosby really liked pudding
pudding's not bad because bill cosby
liked it
right
you can enjoy a pudding pop
yeah very very much so i don't know that
we're actually going to have the time to
get to the practice but do we want to
say anything more about this anti-role
model thing i think i think we can
actually get to the practice practice
pretty short so i'm going to just skip
ahead so practice here
is dissectoral model so i want to
grab someone that you might think of as
a potential model and look objectively
as possible add the role model and make
a list of things that you want to
emulate and what you want to avoid and
the places where this
role model is opaque to you so you know
be aware that there are parts of this
person and the way that they act in the
world that you just will not have access
to
and to make sure that you're not going
down that path of
trying to put things in
where there aren't any information
that's a great point especially if the
role model is somebody who is not
directly accessible to you like a mentor
would be right right and especially with
like how much
on perception and like what is that
uh the public image
professionals are out there yeah yeah
um you know it's it's all over and so
like there's people's jobs just to make
sure that someone looks as good as
possible
a job that has been around for almost a
century i think
yeah
yeah i don't know do you think that
there were no
instances of this in the ancient world
oh there were plenty of it i mean
cicero talks about this in on the orator
how to manage your public image but we
should we should finish up with our
uh final thoughts do you want to lead us
out yes okay
we leave you today with the words the
american intellectual and social critic
james baldwin
children have never been good at
listening to their elders but they have
never failed to imitate them
[Music]
you